und jetzt gehen wir direkt nach Bayern
in eine Kleinstadt und gehen auf die
Suche nach einem Killer dem Disco Killer
vom Eiskeller der Tatort ist Aschau im
Chiemgau ein Ort 20 Minuten von
Rosenheim entfernt ganz unten im Süden
der Republik und dort in Aschau im
Chiemgau dort befindet sich der
Eiskeller das ist dort der eine beliebte
Musikclub dort gehen wir hin denn dieser
Eiskeller das ist der Schauplatz eines
Mordfalls denn dort wurde sie zuletzt
gesehen Hanna das letzte Foto von ihr
aufgenommen von einer Kamera dort im
Eiskeller in diesem ein Musikclub also
in Aschau da hat sie getanzt bis etwa
2:30 Uhr in der Nacht hat den Club wohl
alleine verlassen und zwölf Stunden
später ziehen dann Feuerwehrleute ihre
Leiche aus dem nahegelegenen Fluss der
Prien die Studentin also ermordet
offenbar und wie Müll einfach
weggeworfen ein Mord nach dem Besuch
dort im Eiskeller die Ermittler erinnern
sich sofort da war doch was ja ganz
genau am 6 Jan 2019 also vor bald vier
Jahren da war sie gerade haben sie sie
gesehen Veronika er auf dem Heimweg vom
Musikclub Eiskeller in Aschau 23 Jahre
altes war 4 Uhr morgens damals und da
wurde sie im Schnee von dem Auto gerammt
schwer verletzt stirbt dann später im
Krankenhaus der Fahrer konnte nie
ermittelt werden Bildreporter Jörg
völkerling kennt diese beiden Fälle Jörg
ich grüße dich bei bildlife zwei junge
Frauen beide tot zweimal Aschau zweimal
irgendwie in Verbindung der Musikclub
Eiskeller tanzen Zusammenhang geben
auf ja man natürlich liegen eine gewisse
Parallelen auf der Hand beide Frauen
sind 23 Jahre alt gewesen beide Frauen
haben auch hier in dem
Tourismusbetrieben gearbeitet in der
Region andererseits war das der Tod von
Veronika vor nun fast vier Jahren
möglicherweise eine fahrlässige Tötung
ein Unfallflucht der Täter es gab einen
Verdächtigen es gab Spuren an seinem
Fahrzeug die auf ihn hinwiesen aber er
konnte letztlich nicht über überführt
werden die Ermittlung mussten
eingestellt werden was natürlich auch
ein bisschen auf der Hand liegt diese
Eiskeller ist die beliebteste Disco
zwischen Salzburg und München hier
trifft sich natürlich die Region
insofern ist das auch ein Hotspot keine
Frage und bei Veronika hat damals auch
eine Rolle gespielt dass sie auf der
Straße ging weil es Schnee lag der
Fußgängerweg war nicht geräumt hier
spielt der Fluss eine Rolle die
Naturgewalten spielen eine Rolle denn
die Leiche von Hannah wurde in den
gerade mal 280 Meter von hier entfernten
Fluss Prien offenbar geworfen und dann
10 km weit abgetrieben
jetzt beschäftigt du dich mit dem
aktuellen Mordfall mit dem Mordfall
Hanna was gibt es für an Informationen
über die Todesursache beispielsweise
wir wissen ja dass sie um 2:30 Uhr hier
diesen Club verlassen hat und es wären
nur zehn Minuten bis zu ihrem bis zu
ihrem Elternhaus gewesen und sie muss
entweder schon im Club oder hier im
Umfeld dieser Disco ihr Mördern die Arme
gelaufen sein das davon kann man
ausgehen der Radius in dem die Polizei
sozusagen suchen muss ist sehr klein und
man weiß inzwischen dass es wohl auch
keine keine Tatwaffe im engeren Sinne
gab das Hannah wohl durch Gewalt gegen
den Kopf sagen wir mal ganz grob weil
alles detailliertere dazu wäre ja auch
Täter wissen was die Polizei nicht
preisgeben will zu Tode gekommen ist man
weiß dass sie durch diesen durch die
starke Strömung der Prien auch noch
Verletzungen am Körper entstanden sind
die wohl nicht auf auf äußere
Gewalteinwirkung sondern durch Äste oder
dergleichen zustande gekommen sind was
die Polizei noch nicht endgültig
bestätigen kann ist ob es wirklich ein
Sexualdelikt war da ist die Obduktion
noch nicht eindeutig da muss man noch
warten was jetzt die feingeweblichen
Untersuchungen erbringen unser Bild
Reporter Jörg völkeling auf der Suche
nach dem Disco Killer dort in Aschau im
Chiemgau danke dir
[Musik]